that's okay I want to hear right all of
this we got from the original equation
of motion that's the one that they mean
is the same which sort of makes sense
because that's you as more of
gravitation so that's still operating
okay now this I want to change here okay
so my initial conditions are different
at time zero I want to know where I am
and where I'm heading okay so fired
vertically upwards with speed V capital
B now that's a bit confusing isn't it so
try to be careful I'm gonna put a little
tail on my lowercase V so that you can
try and distinguish okay this is my tail
and there's my big V which is the actual
velocity I start out okay so variable
constant very pleasant and where am i
well I'm not just this D I'm fired from
the surface of the earth right and
remember that X is the distance from the
center so how far is the surface from
the center well they actually tell you
that the radius of you
okay great so now should be the same
equation of motion as a previous
question I want to show you that K has a
particular value right so let's have a
go at this shall we I'm going to use
these conditions yeah I'm gonna say I
can bring in this X and this V together
should put my tail there substitute
yeah we could do that
he got who's who's gotten this far this
[ __ ] up yeah what did you do this way
this is 25 Potter I'm trying to take the
K equals ah good okay I'm getting this
in a second this is what I mean right
you can't just blindly put in clusters
into your equations right because as it
turns out and you look at this you're
trying to get a value for K and they
actually tell you what it is what result
you should get right but you're like
hold on a second that value for K has
nothing to do with this equation right
the very 4k is G R squared please
gravity's involved and there's an R
squared now don't have an R squared and
I don't have a force either I've got
velocity right so where does that fit
him where should I go this is this this
is what I substituted my initial
conditions in okay and it didn't turn
out very useful so where did you put it
down here where did you put it instead
okay now let's be a little more specific
right they actually give us G as just a
constant later on right well I'm gonna
give it as minus G okay cuz I'm actually
going toward the earth does that make
sense so I want X to reduce so I want it
to be - okay with positive I'm heading
away but G is right okay so what am I
gonna do with this well I want to come
back to my original equation for
acceleration so if this is the case okay
force there's only one place where we
actually get this force operating right
because this tells you the particular
force at a particular place when your
place changes the force changes as well
right so where is the force G namely
well it's at the surface of the earth
right so actually if you went close off
you experience more and if you went
further away it experience less right so
here okay now what did I want again I
wanted okay so that gives you now that's
the if you kick your ass whether the
other side there's the result they were
after okay now try not to be over world
more letters but they're just constant
right and you will actually get some
noise for these constants in a second
all right
this pad a Part B now we're going to get
to this squared
I've got V squared being equal to a
constant okay but I actually know what K
is right it's two
swear yeah and this be here right this
lowercase P actually it is another
crispy that's my initial velocity okay
so now when I want to work out my V
squared
I've stuck in initial conditions before
I got a particular C since my initial
conditions have changed I'm gonna get a
different see a different constant okay
in fact I'm going to get this let's see
capital B squared minus so Bri now back
to your equation I wanted an equation
for V squared so lowercase V now this is
actually my variable right is equal to
sorry that's G on squared plus capital B
that constant there right now Catania
it's up just a little bit it's not a
huge amount but this 2gr and that GG r
squared nice together
okay now there's my initial that's my
actually moment my anywhere velocity
okay based on where I am now before we
move any further let's just make sure
that this works out okay does it make
sense sticky and your initial condition
namely that you're sitting on the
surface of planet so your distance from
the center is R the radius if I stick
our into here what happens you stick our
in here yeah whatever R minus one over R
so this pie here looks weird complicated
mess become zero yes
so that means my velocity at that
particular time or equal my initial
velocity
check okay what happens as x increases
as X gets bigger that's this thing
behaving in taken okay so as X gets
bigger right this theme is actually
decreasing right so as X approaches
infinity okay as we get further and
further away but whatever X is
approaching zero yes
so that means 1 over X minus 1 over R is
approaching 4 it's just a protein that
part right because this initial part is
disappearing
so therefore this whole thing to G R
squared times that what is that
approaching
now what does that mean
what does that mean what does that say
about as you go further away what's
happening to your initial blossom it's
getting slower right that's what this
that's the effect that this has okay
it's taking your initial burst and
reducing it by some amount okay now here
is our exit for B okay so so far so good
no actually that's the first part of be
the maximum higher the projectile is
maximum highly projectile now we talked
about how those dogs before right you
could um look at this and say ah
differentiate that what an awful mess
what could we do instead maximum height